Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
December 19th,
2060 what's going on?
However,
um,
oh Jesus Christ my fucking computer.
Every five seconds.
Do you want to download this?
Do you want to do this now?
Do you want to do it in an hour? Should
I remind you later on tonight? Lay.
Give me some fucking space.
Jesus Christ.
He's fucking God. Damn. I don't know man.
I'm not under this shit at all. Just
the level with which that sits fucking,
I guess because of technology,
I am able to do this. You know,
if it was back in the day, I would not
be able to do this. What is this you,
you ask,
maybe you didn't ask.
Maybe I'm doing that thing where
I'm putting words in your mouth,
but if you did ask, you know,
doing a podcast, you know,
I guess there's always a
price to pay and I think that,
I think that that's one to grow on.
Maybe that's the lesson.
I swear to God, I want to start
a fucking church. I got to do it.
And you guys spent watching that, uh, that
woman from King of Queens, she played,
uh, the beautiful wife, you know,
to the guy who drives the truck.
Did you know that was well,
how they've always done sick
comps, the honeymooners. Hey,
I fucking drive a bus and you know,
while I'm,
I'm the wise crack can be pretty wife.
Well Ralph,
maybe if you're wearing a fucking hit,
Yay,
you'd wouldn't drive a bus
yellow one of these days. Alice
power, right? The baby maker,
right. It's not what they did.
Something like that little fucking
ice box in the corner, you know,
and then you get into the 60s,
right?
Sixties was like the Blue Ball era of,
uh,
of sitcoms.
You know what I mean?
Yet I dream of genie and the fucking
guy would Tejas wouldn't banger.
I've talked about this shit before.
I remember watching as a kid.
It's like he'd go, why don't you like
rubbing up against her or something?
You know? I don't even know what sex was.
You know, why? Because it was no internet.
Now if there was internet back when I
was watching that show and I was like
seven or eight, uh, you know, I would
have been like, why does it need,
why did you are a fucking prefers job?
He style over the fucking genie lamp,
you know?
I wouldn't know extra shit.
What the fuck is wrong with kids nowadays?
It's like they just take ticket island.
Mel, I'm going on. An old man ran,
they get on these fucking computers,
right? The parents are like me.
They don't know how to work them. They're
not even interested in him. You know,
we're in the fucking corner and
making homemade apple cider,
getting ready for the holidays,
you know,
wearing a Christmas sweater that
we think actually it looks good.
We're not wearing it. Ironically, will
it go, this is my Christmas sweater, Joe,
my fucking mother's sell this together
for me when I was in high school,
still fit. You know, sweater is always
still fits because they stretch.
They like the sweatpants for your
torso. You know, it takes a while.
Like if you have a homemade sweater, you
know, one of those lobster fishermen.
Once that your mom would make you know
and she just give it to you in the bag
that she bought the yarn and you know,
yeah.
Then one day you'll look at it and some
fucking moths started eating at it and
you just like,
is it the 18 hundreds rarely a
fucking caterpillar learn God,
it's fucking pilots license
and now is eating my sweater.
This is like so fucking 1826 how is
this happening right now for the love of
God? Mom, can you go to the
Ray on store? You don't.
Can you make me a fucking polyester
knitted sweater? How about,
why don't you do that?
Why can't you do that?
I mean Jesus Christ is fucking jumping
toward it and sweat shops around the
world.
Okay,
you got to come and meet with yard.
That's the problem with all the
mothers nowadays. You know what I mean?
Did them and they fucking yard.
They just won't let go of it.
I'm just fucking with you. What kind of
woman knows how to knit anymore? You know,
trying to find a woman that knows how to
knit is like trying to find a guy that
knows, still knows how to
hunt, you know what I mean?
And that even goes for
the fucking rednecks.
You not doing it the way
you fucking, you're, you're,
you're way less fucking,
I don't know what four wheeler
fucking ancestors hunted,
almost talk myself into a
corner and I was like, God,
I don't want to do the Hacky,
you know,
saying your grandfather who were first
had sex with the fucking relative,
you know, I didn't want to say that.
I, I didn't want to go down that road.
I don't even know if that's true,
but how the fuck did that start?
You know what I mean?
One fucking guy banked his sister and
then all of a sudden everybody out there
that has a four wheeler, it's
doing it. You know what I mean?
Okay.
They can just take like,
they don't have Facebook,
you don't have to be lonely.
I like,
have they gotten more
aggressive on that farmers?
Only when they've really just started
shitting on fucking city folk.
You know what I mean?
City folk just don't get it
and they still make
themselves look stupid.
City folk just don't get it.
They could go with global warming,
they could go with overpopulation,
they could go with quality of air,
quality of life space.
There's so many different directions.
Did the hey,
you want to come back to my place and
you go there and it's like some fucking
city apartment. You know what I mean?
With like the kitchen is in the bedroom,
you know,
and the bed folds down from the wall that
you could fucking attack them that way.
You know what I mean? Someone true to
trying to come through their window.
May City folks just don't get it and
then they go to their spread, right?
Yeah.
Fucking get your own parking space.
She not driving around the block like
for fucking nine hours trying to find
alternative side of the street.
Fucking parking.
There's all these different things.
Water levels rising.
You know,
I saw this one of these men in the street
things I've been watching that debt
channel Vice, you guys, what's the vice
channel? It's a fucking great channel.
Reminds me a lot of ways
that a little bit of um,
MTV during the early days where like they
had a lot of funny promo commercials.
I don't know why more fucking networks
don't do that. Cause you know,
he usually fast forward, I turned the
channel when there's a commercial,
but they get like,
they are funny fucking commercials.
Like there's some talk show on there.
These two black dudes right now,
at least one black dude and one
guy sort of Puerto Rican maybe. Uh,
maybe he's light skinned. I
don't know. I'm too white to
understand. Right. So they,
they do a talk show,
so they're hyping it and they're
showing like the New York City skyline,
like they always do before a talk show.
And it was a,
I'm going to fuck up the joke. It was
something like no big guests, no band,
no audience,
no white dudes and a then they cut to the
Promo and somebody comes out, you know,
and I can know what the fuck was. I was
watching, I was like, this is funny.
This looks like way back in the
day when I would see like Randy,
the redwoods agenda, taxi driver, you
know, they would have like funny promos.
I Dunno why they ever got away
from that. But, um, anyways,
Oh, speaking of that,
speaking of non whities,
um,
I saw a fucking front man this weekend
and abandon it was fucking unbelievable,
right? I went down, um, uh,
the other day I did, uh,
the dark matter podcast,
um,
which is Dave Navarro's plowed cast.
And um,
had a great time on that. And
afterwards they were like, yeah, hey,
Dave's doing his show down at the Roxy.
You want to come down Friday,
Saturday night? I guess he, I mean
I'm, I'm in the dark hair. Literally,
no pun intended. I didn't know he did
this just Christmas show every year. Um,
and it was like an all star lineup.
You don't know who the
fuck's coming out and um,
you just go to the show and then they
just start bringing people out. And um,
so I went down there to go
see the show and I mean,
I knew it was going to be good.
Dude. It was fucking ridiculous,
the amount of people
that they had coming out,
which of course I'm going to fucking
forget the names and everything, but uh,
you just, you know, some
of them come out, this guy,
because they sang student
sang the immigrant song and
something else and fucking
murdered it.
I never even heard of the guy fucking
murdered at the band was unbelievable.
The viral was killing it.
And then they,
then they brought out Macy
gray and then she sang, uh,
the fuck did she saying she's saying
the pretenders brass in pocket and then
she's saying Radiohead creep. I was
just like, Jesus Christ, what the fuck?
And then they brought out Cypress Hill
and no one was doing like their own style
of music that everybody would like switch
it up. So then they bring out this,
they get this fucking intro,
which no performer wants to get.
Right. The guy goes to do the
intro and he just goes, you know,
Billy Morrison was, and just fucking
everybody, right? It goes, um, all right,
this next guy, you know, people
suggested him for this show. Uh,
you know, first few like
gay, you know, we don't know.
We don't know if he's right for this show.
And then we saw him and he
absolutely blew us away.
Our jaws were on the ground. I'm telling
you, this fucking guy is unbelievable,
Yada Yada. And I'm thinking, I was
in the crowd going, oh no, not that.
That intro was to fucking war. You can't
follow it. It's, I can stand up comedy.
This guy he's wanting to on
a best work in comms today,
he reinvented the Mike Stand, eh,
Betty Murphy was still doing stand up.
He'd be be asking this guy
to write from it. You know,
they start giving you a fucking intro
like that. You'd sit in the back like guy,
he tone it down,
tone it down,
right to this guy came out and
totally fucking lived up to it.
It's this guy, he's a rapper. I man,
I don't know shit about hip hop or
anything like this Guy Post Malone.
So the guy on stage,
for whatever reason,
I said this guy's responsible for
Justin Bieber's career. Right.
Which I don't know why you would say
that in front of a bunch of fucking 40 to
50 something year old white people.
Right.
So this dude comes walking out and
there's a few people bowing like
couple, you know, like five people
because of the Justin Bieber thing.
I love people in their forties and 50s
who fucking talk about how bad Justin
Bieber's music is. It's like, really, it
doesn't speak to you. You're fucking dope.
It's not for you.
You know what I mean?
That's like getting mad at the fucking a,
I don't to insult the guy,
but you know what I mean? It's,
it's for, it's for younger people.
You know what I mean?
I think camp like,
I don't understand people getting their
forties and 50s and they just, they,
they don't understand that, um, somebody,
his perspective as a 20 something year
old is not going to seem like the same as
theirs. And we sit there going like,
what the fuck is he tied that? And like,
that's bullshit. That's a, that's a stupid
Bible, blah, blah, blah. And it's like,
yeah, yeah. That's what you did when
you were there that age and somebody,
he'll be in his forties and look
back at himself at 2123 gun.
What the fuck was I thinking?
Right.
Somehow like four or five people don't
get it and they literally Boeing,
you know Justin Bieber at a show,
Justin Bieber is an ad.
So this guy comes fucking walking out and
he just walks up to the microphone and
he goes, what's up la?
I'm drunk as fuck. Right?
So immediately the crowd just starts
cheering and uh, he goes, I, you know,
I'm using, you know, I'm a
rapper and I know everybody I've,
I was assuming, and the crowd was
like, were you going like, yeah,
I'm completely unfamiliar with you.
I am a white guy pushing 50.
I have no idea where you are.
Right?
So they start playing
rage against the machine,
killing in the name of, and
I'm like going, Oh God, Oh,
rappers gonna sig did they got
the auto tune on? You know,
is this going to be like,
uh,
so you're going to have too
much deodorant under his arms?
Like fucking ll cool j when he did the
unplugged, what's going to happen here?
Dude, this guy, this guy
fucking murdered the song,
fucking murdered this song.
Okay.
Don't just took the whole thing to
another level and it never came back down
again.
Everybody else match this guy.
This fucking dude was unbelievably
sang that song. And then he's saying,
Alison chains wood and
fucking murdered both of them.
Um,
okay.
And you literally felt it in the crowd.
Everybody on their phones going like,
who the fuck is this guy? I got a
dog download some of his shit. Um,
yeah.
Oh, and here's hilarious thing.
So later on that weekend,
I'm watching vice and there's another
funny promo. He's sitting there,
that Guy Post Malone, right? And I
was sitting there with near gone.
That's the fucking guy I saw that
the guy that murdered that song,
those two songs. Right. So, um,
yeah,
he was talking about conspiracy theory.
I don't even know what
the commercial was about.
It was just him talking to another guy.
I'm telling you,
it's very like early days of MTV. He was
just talking about conspiracy theory.
And, uh, being able to teleport
and he was just going like say,
here's area 51, right? Which of course he
picks that rather than saying San Diego,
okay. He goes, here's area 51
right here. Here's Australia.
If you want to fly from area
51 to Australia, you've got
to fly all the way here.
You know, and he draws the arc to
it just didn't draw a straight line.
Like someone actually
understands aviation, right.
Because this is what creeped me out
because if you just drew a straight line,
it'd be like, all right, this
guy's, this guy's out of his mind.
But the second he drew the arc, I'm like,
Oh fuck, I'm buying into this theory,
right? And he goes, um, and he
goes, well, with teleportation,
they just do stuff like this and he just
takes the paper and the x area 51 was
in the expo Australia's he just
takes the paper and he just folds it.
He pushes them together. He
goes, it's like that. He goes,
I know you guys think of mine in my mind,
but I know this shit is true.
And I was like, this guy's brain.
That's what my brain tells me, you know.
So I don't know anything about
any of his, any of his, uh,
okay.
Any of his music. But I'm definitely
gonna Watch, download some of his shit.
If anybody knows what is best
album is or whatever, you know,
a good jump off point for that guy.
Um, it would be, it would be, uh,
be tremendous. Um, so
anyways, oh by the way,
in a viral fucking killed
the guitar solo in that too.
I was wondering how the
hell he was going to do it.
And I don't know if they came up with a,
uh,
an effects pedal that made
the noise that the dude from a
okay,
you know, fucking rage against
the machine. You know, cause he,
when he came out of here that will, those
weird sounds that he made, I don't know.
You know, I was in over my head
musically about fucking 15 minutes ago,
but whatever. And I want to thank
everybody at dark matter for, uh,
for hooking me up to see that show.
Okay.
It was fucking great, man.
Just a great God damn show.
So of course I talked to Dean del Rey
who everything. He goes, Oh yeah man,
I, he goes, I went to that show
it like the fifth anniversary.
And it was like fucking Ozzie,
Lemmy and Steven Tyler.
And I was just like, Oh
fuck you man. Fucking,
you're never going to beat Dean
del Ray with the fucking, uh,
I went to a concert story, fucking
guy seen everything. So anyway,
so I'm watching this vice channel.
I know,
I'm just plowing through this shit
fucking all over the place. Um,
and my wife just kept, you
know, recording this shit.
They were co she recorded something about,
um,
okay,
like Dj's,
she recorded something about
these fucking kids of those,
you know, oil barons or whatever,
oil money in Saudi Arabia.
So watching both of these,
right. The DJ thing, you know,
it's just something I'd seen before the
show and how much money that they're
making. And I'm in Vegas. And, uh,
it was funny though,
actually actually actually asking a couple
of them what the future was in a few
of them understood it. And a
few of them are just like, yeah,
it's never going to end. It's like, dude,
at some point you're going to be the
bgs in January of 1980 it happens to all
genres of music and the in the
so few bands figuring out how to do it,
how to age gracefully
from one era to another.
Um,
and like I was saying like,
I think I was talking about that and I
can't remember what fucking podcasts is.
You have to, I don't know how to do
it, but somehow you have to, like,
your music has to age with you so you
don't look like a fucking moron. Um,
like Justin Bieber has got to write some
fucking middle age shit when he's in
his middle age, you know, cause he
can't be singing about whatever the,
whatever the fuck he thinks about, you
know what I mean? They look stupid at 40,
you know, and it makes every people,
everybody in the crowd feels old.
Then you start, oh my God,
we're gonna die. You know,
you just see your mortality
when they come out. I mean,
the first time that I saw that was when,
uh,
okay,
like 10 years ago when David Lee Roth
came back with van Halen and I went to go
see van Halen, I was like, oh my God,
this is going to be fucking great, right.
I can't believe he's back.
I saw a diamond,
Dave went on the Itam and smile
tours can be easily thrown, you know,
just think he's gonna be throwing fucking
kicks and jumping off the stage doing
the fucking split. Right. And a dude,
he came walking out on stage and I
sweated within two. I was like, oh my God.
And like put it five seconds is
like, ah, fuck. He's all dumb old.
We're going to die.
Like this wave of fucking depression
just hit me until I really realized
like, wait a minute. Like, you know,
guitarists and drummers don't get old.
I mean, they do, but like, you know,
they can still fucking, you know, if
they have a technique or whatever,
they can still fucking,
yeah.
Still fucking shred and I forgot that
Eddie and Alex have been playing again for
like 50 fucking years and
they were unbelievable.
The singer has it the worst
because your voice naturally drops.
And of course everyone from my era
actually fucking sang, you know,
not to shit on Justin Bieber born.
I was watching that Dj thing on
the vice channel. They fucking, um,
okay.
He shows up at some, some pool party,
you know, where everybody's fucking,
you know,
turning the cameras around,
doing selfies and the peace sign
and the duck lips and all that shit.
And he shows up to sing his song and
he's just clearly fucking lips thinking
he's not even trying to do a good
job and everybody's freaking out.
There was a few times,
like he took the mic away from his mouth,
pointed at the crowd. He could still
hear him singing and nobody gave a shit.
There was no band,
there was nothing.
And all these Yolo Douche is, we're
going fucking nuts. It's like,
how is that acceptable?
I don't know that,
that shit makes me feel old.
Like back in the day,
if you ever got caught Milli Vanilli
oh, the whole fucking he, Millie,
Millie add vanilla,
his whole fucking white through that.
Nobody gave a Shit Twan 20, 30
fucking years earlier. You know,
I guess it's cause those guys
technically never even sang on the track.
I dunno, everybody's doing fucking
commercials now. I mean, I,
it's just back in the,
it's the whole thing is just changed.
He just do whatever you want.
You don't have to sing. You
can fucking, uh, you know,
you can lip sync your way with the,
your hit song through a commercial
for fucking under Roos and uh,
it actually equates to more
album downloads of a deli.
I should just be sitting on a porch right
now watching young people walking by
yelling at them. That's what this podcast
is just slowly becoming. Um, so anyways,
I'm watching that channel and uh,
the next thing near recorded
was a, this thing about the, uh,
it looked like those same guys
that I saw when I was in London.
The Middle Eastern dudes
who fly on a cargo plane,
fly in all their fucking cars.
With this same ridiculous rap,
you know?
Or maybe it's a paint job. I think
it's a wrap that they put on there.
You know what I mean?
They've got like the fucking a,
it's like that mirrored finish,
like those three people in Shanna and
now with the gold suit's still do that to
like Mercedes and all that. Well,
when they're back in their country,
another status symbol is to own a,
uh,
like endangered species or a
exotic animals is they call them.
Okay.
And these fucking guys,
they owned like a cheetahs
and lions and tigers.
It was the most disturbing fucking thing
and aren't even coming into this and
like a Peter Way, I just sat there going
like, dude, that is a fucking lion.
You've got it on a leash.
Okay.
And these things kept,
you know,
they have their friends and they'd sort
of lunge at him and then the friends
would jump out of the way and be like,
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. I'm like laughing.
It's just like if you saw how big these
fucking things where it's just like,
okay,
they could like sort of
like at the 30% like bitch,
slap a refrigerator and the thing
would tip over and go flying across the
fucking room. You know what I mean?
And these guys are fucking with DC,
so this fucking lay goes over there.
This white lady making white people look,
look fucking stupid as shit.
She's like,
she fucking goes over to
this guy's God damn house.
He's got a giant fucking lion. All
right? And he goes, well, we'll get,
or a tiger assumption. And he
goes, I will get you comfortable.
We'll let you play with
some smaller ones first.
So she's playing with these
little ones in. Immediately I say,
I wouldn't fuck with that. I did. Long
time ago I was on Opie and Anthony.
They brought in a fucking
baby tiger and little ones,
little white ones is some shit.
And they asked me if they wanted a whole,
if I wanted to hold it. I was
like, no. The thing was upset.
It didn't want to fucking be there.
And I've been scratched by a house
cat fucking killed right now.
All it got me with one goddamn
claw when write down my forearm,
I had to put all this shit
on it so I wouldn't get some
sort of God damn disease.
And I'm looking at this,
this cute little baby tiger alive,
whatever the fuck it was.
And I sick freed and Roy once the Mariah
Carey one where it's all fucking white,
you know,
and uh,
I'm just looking at the size
of its fucking pause. I'm like,
then things pause already a like
four times the size of a house cat.
I've got scratched by a house cat.
This thing's in a bad mood.
I don't want to fuck, I don't want to
deal with the thing. You know, it's funny,
he's actually scratched Anthony,
if I remember correctly.
And he had to get like a tetanus shot
or something,
some sort of ointment had to be put
on his fucking neck. So anyways,
so this lady goes in there, right? And
she's playing with them. She's like,
oh my God, there's sword Jorell. And um,
was really not impressed
with the intellect of the
woman that thought they could
have got somebody a lot
of fucking smarter. Right.
So then she goes outside
to meet this line.
Okay,
this lioness,
and there's no way to describe
to you how big a fucking lion is.
It's not very often that you get to see
a person standing next to a Goddamn lied.
She walks up to the,
to in the general area,
this thing and the things
immediately looking at her,
the way of fucking wild animal
looks at you. You know what I mean?
It's the same way.
I've always said this is the same way,
like a fucking hooker looks at you
where there's no bullshit. You know,
you're going to a bar, some woman looks
at you, you know, chewing. If you know,
she's just trying to get a fucking drink
it, well, how could it looks at you? It's,
it's a real deal. Like,
yeah, I will fuck you. Okay.
You have to circumstances or are,
you know,
if you got the money I will
fuck you. Right. It's the
same thing with like lions.
They looking at you like, if the
opportunity arises, I will kill you.
You know, dogs don't look at you like
that. Fucking lions look at, you know,
cats attempted house cats,
you know,
you turn around and he'd catch
up stock and you and shit,
but then you look at them and then
they fucking run away. All right,
picture a cat doing that.
A house cat.
But you turn around and it's aligned and
it doesn't run away if fucking lunges
at you or maybe it gives you that
refrigerator bitch slap, right?
So this fucking thing is looking at her
and he's the owner who has no training
whatsoever. Brings his fucking thing.
I'll do, my palms were like sweaty.
I, I had to get, well when I was watching
it in bed, I literally stood up going,
what the fuck are you doing?
So the thing comes over,
immediately starts crawling on top of her,
it's on top of her.
And then she puts her hands on the side
of the thing. It starts like, like,
you know,
rubbing it like it's a giant dog.
And all I remember was that there's a
youtube video of that stunt man and worked
with bears and he had brought us some
sort of relative in there who wanted to
learn how to work with bears.
And he told him to keep his hands down
by his side and the bear came up and like
stood up on its back legs,
put its paws on the dude shoulder.
And he instinctively put his
hands on either side of the bear,
which the bear took as like an aggressive
move and one of the fight and it
fucking killed this guy. So she puts
her hands down and I see that and go,
oh fuck is this thing like a bear?
I don't fucking know.
And all of a sudden,
um,
she got just a little bit scared and
then the thing like collapsed down on her
and it got weird really quick.
And then the guy stood up with this rope
fucking leash and like quickly tries to
pull the lion away, what she does
and this woman gets up like, Oh wow,
that was Helen's.
I guess I feel like that was
like a spiritual experience
of Albert's like Bitchy,
woman's got fucking killed
and then the guy goes, yeah,
you got scared and it senses
your fear and then Oh God,
thank God she didn't make any high
pitched noise like the sound of an animal
like suffering. You know what I mean?
You have any other that like a dog toy,
you know when they bite on it and
it makes that high pitched noise,
it excites the Predator.
And um,
so I say to Nia,
I go,
how far into this show before they
show us somebody who got killed? I go,
I say about 17 minutes.
They did.
And it was at the end of the show and
they were just like two weeks after we
left. Um, this fucking woman,
basically the housekeeper comes in.
All right.
She didn't fucking do anything.
She's not like these fucking guys
who for some reason, like it's,
it's just total like male ego shit trying
to outdo the other fucking rich guy
down the street that
they get these things.
They don't know anything about
the animals. They fucking,
at least that's the way it was presented.
They didn't know shit about the fucking
animals. And then they were like, no,
the thing has a better life live in here.
It's walking around in a fucking cage.
You know, it was like, do what you
want to walk around in a cage. I mean,
you could always get knifed,
you could get killed the way
an animal couldn't in the wild.
Okay,
so fucking lion who's killing a
lion other than another human being.
Um, so anyways, uh,
this fucking housekeeper came in and uh,
she got mauled by these fucking lines
and they bring the woman in and the guy
tried to see a dog did it.
And they were like, ah,
these injuries are a little more than
a dog. And then the owner is like,
well, whatever, do you
mean? It's like, well,
she's missing her left arm and the
claw marks on this. And He, so,
you know what the fucking asshole
did? He had three lions. He went home,
he shot all of them, and then burn
their bodies out in the desert. So we,
you know, so nothing would fucking happen
to them. And, uh, it was just like, again,
it's like, yeah, there you go. They go
fucking inevitable. They had like Cheetos,
this guy's riding in a fucking six
wheeled Mercedes with a fucking Cheetah.
Okay.
And that woman's getting in
the car guy. Oh, it's, it's,
it's acting just like a dog. It's
panning. It's looking out the window.
Maybe they had to get somebody,
I'm not saying she was not a smart person,
she just wasn't very aware
of the situation, I feel.
And I just kept hearing like,
there was,
back in the day,
like 50 def jam comics did bits about
how white people fuck with wild animals.
And so in a way I'm like,
oh, this is good for once.
It's not white people being idiots with
wild animals, you know, now it's Arabs.
Let's, let's, uh, you know,
take a little heat off a Whitey and then
they bring this white lady in there and
she fucking does everything that,
you know,
every one of those bits says that we do.
Yeah.
So anyways, let's get to some of the,
some of the reeds here for the week.
If I can,
if my fucking
okay.
Computer isn't going to tell me to
fucking, I dunno. Updates something. Um,
oh Jesus. Here we go. There we
go. Oh wait, I have to promote it.
This thing real quick. All right. I was
supposed to promote this regular hero,
um,
year in review. You can donate now and
be irregular hero to change a life today.
These people work around the world
to help the disadvantaged. They uh,
they are a non another
yet another nonprofit.
And I'm assuming that because
it's on my podcast that this is a,
this is actually a legit one.
You know,
they help out with hurricane Matthew,
skid row at risk youth.
Uh Oh.
Regularly Heroes Show [inaudible].
Okay.
Oh fuck. I've done one of these. Oh,
this is what Steve Simone thing, right.
The regular heroes show has been a
great fun and an awareness raiser.
Thanks to comedians. Bill Berg, Gabriel
Iglesias, Dane Cook, Daniel Tosh,
Chris Hardwick,
Chris Delea,
the world at the world famous
comedy store in the Improv. Yeah.
This is actually a legit one in a,
in a world where so many of
these nonprofits are, um,
a complete horse shit.
This is actually a legit one,
which is a very nice thing. Um, because
everything is a fucking nonprofit.
Like you remember that,
that that lady from a couple months back,
she,
uh,
she lost a job at that
nonprofit yet another nonprofit.
Uh, when she said that horrible
shit about Michelle Obama, you know,
and of course wrote it like a
dope. She said something like, uh,
it will be so refreshing to have a classy,
beautiful,
dignified first lady in the White House.
You mean that trophy wife?
Well, cause she wears a red blouse. All
of a sudden she's fucking, uh, you know,
a better person. She wrote, I'm
tired of seeing ape in heels,
not an a n a ape in heels.
And ape is capitalized.
Like it's a, I don't know somebody's
name or some shit like that.
And so of course she gets fucking,
she gets bounced out of this nonprofit.
She gets fired because everybody knows
that makes you less racist. You're racist,
and then you lose your job.
And then you go, oh, wait a
minute, what was I thinking?
Everybody is equal. Um,
so anyways, then the, uh,
the fucking mayor from this town,
Clay County is something Virginia,
Virginia,
West Virginia I guess
backed up her Goddamn, uh,
why you would do that. You
know, even if you were races,
you think you'd be smart enough,
keep your fucking mouth shut.
This person co-signed and
what the other person said.
And then the mayor had to fucking
resigned. So anyways, they actually,
so they fired the first lady who said
it from the Clay County Development
Corporation. Nonprofit. They're a
corporation that developed shit. And then,
but it's not for profit.
Well, let me ask you this.
How is this woman not homeless?
I don't get how you work for a
nonprofit and you're not homeless.
If there's no profit, how do they pay
you? This is what all corporations do.
I'm in business.
I'm in business with a certain corporation
that claims in 90 to $180 million
loss a year. And the people I work
with are buying mansions out here,
redoing them.
I don't know how that works.
That's actually a different thing because
they're not considered a nonprofit.
They're considered a business entity.
And if he,
if you don't show that
you've earned any money,
then you don't have to pay any taxes.
Um, so the corporation doesn't,
but then everybody draws a salary.
Now you have to pay taxes on,
um, on the salary that you drew.
But however, if you just say,
and you're not making a profit,
you don't have to pay any taxes.
And I would think that all that extra
money that you didn't pay taxes on,
you then just disperse
amongst your employees, right?
So rather than making a million a year,
you make 2 million a year and
then you pay taxes on that. Right.
I don't know how it
works. I don't, you know,
I'm too stupid to figure out
how that shit works. But, um,
for the life of me,
I looked up this nonprofit
trying to figure out what
the fuck they do. I cannot,
I can't figure it out. So anyways,
they fired these fucking lady. And um,
then like a month later, they
just reinstated her. They
just reinstated her. And,
uh, I don't know. To me
that is the Trump influence.
I think that that's what
everybody learned from Trump.
It's just like you just say, Hey, you
know, that's locker room talk or a,
you know, alright, he's fired and he
comes back. Hey, you know, I'm back. Yeah.
You know, I lie, I left for six
weeks and, uh, back. Uh, you know,
and what I love with media is there's
no follow up after the first story.
The first story is done.
There's the,
there's the whole fucking everybody
flipping out. Let's go burn the witch.
And then once it dies down, then you
just bring the person back and nobody,
they've moved onto something else.
Um, I don't know. It's really bizarre.
I just don't know how somebody could
fucking be in business with somebody like
that. It's fucking nuts. Anyways,
all right, me undies, uh, oh Jesus.
But Opal, me, undies,
me undies rubbing up on
your Cogley Doo Doo Doo. Me,
Andy's me undies. It's like
a sheepskin fucking saw. Ugh.
It's so fucking soft up against your Tate.
You know,
you fucking love it. Um, your Dick,
you will page with a pair of fucking me
undies. Why would you paint your deck?
I don't know. How many fucking
times can I sing this picture.
A world in a world where putting on a
new pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a
better day. You know, I bet.
Where's me undies or lives in me undies?
Lifestyle is Mariah Carey.
I noticed the second time I brought
her up, but that fucking channel,
Nia keeps watching.
I know one of these reality shows that's
following Mariah Carey around. Dude,
she's fucking hilarious.
Every fucking shot.
She's like laying in a bed in an evening
gown with heels on full makeup and
everything with a glass of wine.
It's like in the 1950s what people
thought rich people did all day.
Just laying around with like,
you know,
some fucking $300,000 diamond necklace.
It's like, we get it. You're a diva.
Jesus Christ. She never
wear sweatpants. You know,
just to have a fucking white
Zinfandel over there. Um,
anyways, it says, think about it under,
where's the first thing you put on in
the last thing you take off unless you
weird. You know what if you don't
like your torso, what have you,
one of those guys that fucks with his
shirt on, you know, you sweaty tee shirt,
right? You know what I mean? He's
still a good tee shirt on. You know,
ladies,
if you're fucking a guy wears man ted.
That's when you know he's really letting
you win is when he takes the t shirt
off to our Jesus. But why
would you say that? All right.
Think about it and underwear.
It's about why would you settle for
anything less than the best feeling
underwear on the planet.
Be undies focuses solely on producing the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
Uh,
my friends at me and he sent me a few
pairs awhile back and now I can't imagine
wearing anything else.
Why do you keep putting it in the copy?
You sent me two pairs.
I wore them.
One I liked the other with
the Greg Lou gain is cut.
And I don't think I wasn't in that shape.
You know, you sent me the Olympic diver.
Fucking scabies there.
You know
Jesus Christ.
I went from muffin top to like,
I don't know what the fuck
croissant. What's the next
one? Up to pastry ladder. Um,
it really makes each day that much better
for the price of two cocktails me on.
We'll deliver your new favorite pair
of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guarantee you try them on.
And if they aren't the most comfortable,
best feeling under where you've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you keep your
first pair for free. Well, obviously,
what are you going to take it back?
Like that fucking mattress company.
These Uber Cozy undies
are sold exclusively on.
They give me undies website where you'll
enjoy free shipping and the U S and
Canada.
And for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order.
But you have to order our,
go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr
to get 20% off. That's me.
undies.com/burr. All right,
give me loot crate everybody.
Hey nerds, wake the fuck up if we go, uh,
be the envy of your friends and get
your 100% exclusive crates that Luke
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter
my code birth to save $3 off any new
subscription. What the fuck is
a Luke rate? Oh, here we go.
Wait until I t oh wait until I tell you
slips. He supposed to be excited here.
Wait. Oh wait until I tell
you about December crate.
It'll have you fight the power man.
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical fashion
Isa Nisa than try loop where monthly
wearables and accessories with coke
classics and your favorite franchises.
If you wanted to get fancy,
get a bigger box and even
bigger loop with Luke Craig DX.
Want to geek out a your pet try loop pets
offer expires December 19th at 9:00 PM
pathetic. Get ready for December's
rebellious theme revolution.
They're always watching.
I have no idea what any of this shit is,
but I know nerds are loving this.
They designed a system to keep you down
and they're metal. Some hello friends.
It's time for a revolution.
December's crate features exclusive
items from assassin's creed. No way,
Mr. Robot, Holy Shit. Firefly.
What the fuck is that?
Our monthly tee shirt and pin and more
including an exclusive Funko pop telling
you I say this every week. That
sounds like a fucking dad. Gene Band.
Funko pop. You take
elements of Funk, you know,
you're like really into tower of power.
It's like a James Brown kind of thing.
And we met, we mash it.
We do or what are the,
one of the kids call it a fucking
combining there of two songs with the same
tempo of more contemporary
things. Our kids love it. Uh,
do not wait. You have until
the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific,
eight maybe our next year
when Navarro does is show.
Maybe we'll have some members
of Funko pop, c'mon, um,
Pacific to subscribe to for December's
crate. When is, when it's over.
It's over.
No more crates.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and
enter my code birth to save $3 off any
new subscription today. How many
more fucking things that are there?
Uh,
I don't know how to reel.
All right guys,
can you handle one more?
Can I just do one more just to fucking
plow through this shit? All right.
Now that you know how
to dress like a nerd,
now that your balls and nice and soft,
you know at some point you're
going to want a sandwich, right?
Blue Apron. Everybody not to be confused
with read a print. This is blue apron.
This is for the Democrats
only. All right. Not, oh,
not if you want to cry into your
meal after Trump gets sworn in,
you got to go to blue apron. Not all
ingredients are created equal. Fresh,
high quality ingredients
make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from. Um,
talk about how blue fuck you.
I'll talk about what I want to talk about.
Affordable for less than
$10 per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meal for right.
We got your covered.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each
week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you.
Holy Shit is that cornflakes recipes
are not repeated within a year,
so you'll never get bored.
You like Mariah Carey with other
fucking even counts every fucking time.
She's got a different one.
Flexible.
Customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment. So you
only get deliveries when you want them.
Easy. You want it easy. You don't want
to thank you. Fucking dope. Here we go.
Each meal comes from with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card,
card and proportion ingredients and
can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
Just like Rachel Ray over there.
Um, guaranteed blue aprons,
fresh shrimps freshness,
guarantees,
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook or they'll
make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get the
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/bar
you'll love how good it feels and tastes.
You're creating credible home cooked
meals, blue apron, so don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/bar blue apron.
A better way to cook.
Why do they write so much fucking copy?
It's like, yeah, I get it. I get it. Okay.
I get all these aren't all, well,
some of these are reads I fucked up.
I only have one left. Oh my God.
This is great. There's only one left.
Everybody. Then I get into the questions
for the week. Perfect. All right.
Seatgeek everyone buying tickets online
for sports and concert has been a
confusing process for a long time.
It has.
It's always been hard to find the best
deal for that game or show you want to go
to and none of those older
tickets sites want to change that,
but Siki is different.
They'd come along and created an amazing
APP and website that makes it easier
for every fan to bind,
sell tickets.
Everything about seat geek is designed
to make life easier for sports and music
fans.
See,
Keith does all the price comparisons for
you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get
the best possible deal. See,
Keith does all the work and you
save time and money. Best of all,
my listeners get $20 a $20 rebate
off their first SeatGeek purchase.
To get your $20 rebate on tickets,
download the [inaudible] APP.
Go to the settings tab and
click on the add a promo code.
Allow them to access all your photos and
to track you long after you've bought
the seats. Enter Promo Code
[inaudible]. This is an Uber.
Enter Promo Code Burp.
See Keke.
We'll send you $20 after you've
made your first ticket purchase.
Download the seat Geek App and
enter the Promo Code bird today.
All righty then.
All right,
so according to the emails,
somebody wanted me to look at this
fucking thing and it's simply says crazy
Asian sport.
Saw The son read it and
needed you to see it.
A Merry Christmas. Twinkle lies.
All right, let's see what this is.
Oh my God. All right. Let me hit pause
here. This is basically, this is,
I want to go to this.
All right.
There's this whole
group of fucking dude's,
they're all dressed in white.
Oh my God.
They're all huddled around a pole and
there's a guy sitting on top of the
fucking Paul and then another group of
dudes come in wearing orange shirts and
the fucking,
they all have on like Olympic
boxing headgear and then when,
when the fucking orange Jude's coming in,
they're trying to knock
the guy off to Paul.
This is like fucking
ads fighting each other.
Yeah,
dude,
you fucking asshole.
How can you show me this and
not tell me what sport this is?
They tried to knock the guy off the
fucking poll. What is this called?
And what happens is,
is basically everybody gets piled on.
Once the orange crew comes
in, oh, there's a weak guy.
He turned and ran the other fucking way.
They start jumping up on top
of each other. Oh my God.
That would be so fucking claustrophobic.
It's basically like a rugby scrum.
If you could throw fucking
punches and you climb in,
just imagine a rugby scrum
and rather than the ball,
one of the rugby dudes was sitting up
on a pole and they're trying to fucking
knock them off.
Wow,
dude.
They're just kicking each other in
the face. I swear to God, you know,
how the fuck did I get so lucky to
be born in this goddamn country?
Where did they at least pretend
to give a shit about wellbeing?
And your like, that is a fucking
hardcore sport. You know what?
Hat's off to fucking Asia right there.
I would love to see them and try
to get this. This is barbaric.
You don't try to do it in our country.
Like is everybody's listening
from America. My country,
I should say this is barbaric.
This is,
this is promoting violence against
people at different kinds of shirts on.
I mean, I don't even understand. What is
it? What is, what is the purpose of this?
Um, can you please tell
me the name of that sport?
Am I ever gonna get over this fucking
cough and smoked a cigar and forever I'm
getting eight hours sleep.
Not really, you know,
knee is tossing and turning
and every fucking minute now.
I literally, you know, I,
I, I sleep in bed for like half the night
and then after awhile I just ended up
going upstairs and I fall asleep, you
know? And I want to do the same thing.
Like when the baby comes, I'm just going
to be one of the baby cries too much.
I'm just going to be like,
you know what,
I can't deal with either one of you and
I'm going to go upstairs and I'm going
to put on an evening God
like Mariah Carey and
inlay here with my fucking diamonds on.
I Dunno,
maybe it's just for the show,
but I just look at it as like,
this person is out of there.
If they just at some point it's just
completely lost touch of reality.
Um, there's something about that when you
get like backup dancers and they're all
hanging on your every word and they,
and they literally want to be you.
Like there's no way to keep,
keep yourself tethered to any sort
of fucking reality. Um, all right.
Advice, age, different
story. First of all,
did I talk about everything I wanted to
fucking talk about this week? I'm all,
let's talk about how you guys doing with
your Chi. If you late to the podcast,
you can still start right now,
man.
I've been trying to do a half hour cardio
every single day because as you know,
between Thanksgiving and new year's,
she eat all of this fucking shit.
You put on weight and then you got to do,
you just start the year behind the
eight ball by the eight ball. Right?
I was like,
I'm not fucking doing that.
So as of December 1st I've
been trying to do a cardio,
a half hour cardio every
single fucking day. And um,
of course I fucked up, right? I, um,
what did I do?
I,
I made it through the first 11 days and
then December 12th I had a busy morning
and you really got to knock it out in
the morning, which I didn't. And uh,
the day got longer and longer.
And then I came home and he was watching
some fucking TV and she was just like,
I need comfort. And I
was just like, all right,
acting like I was a good
husband rather than like,
I don't want to get them that fucking
elliptical again. So I missed a half hour.
On the 12th, 13th I did my
half hour. So I had 1,213 days,
14th I missed. Then I was like, fuck,
this is becoming a trend now.
I owe that machine down there.
60 minutes plus the 30 for today.
That was Friday,
December 15th so I got on that
elliptical bop, blah blah blah,
Dodo, no baby baby red cakes. Um,
I got on the thing and I
did an hour and 11 minutes,
71 minutes out of the 90 minutes.
I just looked at it like
it was a basketball game or
a sporting event that was
down by 90 points.
And so the next day I started my day,
I was down 19 points plus the 30 I had
to do and I ended up doing an hour on the
elliptical.
So now I was up 11 minutes
and then I liked it.
I liked the results of doing a
fucking hour. So then, uh, on,
say I did a an hour and four minutes.
So then now I'm up. I was down
90 minutes now I was up, uh,
an hour and 15, also known as 75 minutes.
And then yesterday I did an hour,
15 minutes. Uh, so I don't even
know what I'm up at this point.
45 minutes plus the next
to 45, I'm actually up 90
minutes, something like that.
I don't know what the fuck it is. I can't
really remember. But all I wanted to do,
I was going to do a half hour every
day and that was going to be a,
so 31 days it'd be 15 and a
half hours of cardio. But uh,
now I think I'm just going to do hours
every day for the rest of the fucking
year. I weighed myself the
other day. I was one 77.
Now when I came back from fucking Europe,
I was a buck 90.
So I've taken 13 pounds off since,
um,
since that trip. So I dunno, it's
all about the fucking cardio. Um,
I would love to do that. You know,
if you know what the reality is,
is if you've got an elliptical every
day and did fucking 60 minutes,
if you just did that, you know,
and, and when you do that,
when you put together a playlist,
that's when you got to love. I tell you,
you got to love like bands like
iron maiden or they have six,
seven minutes songs, you know, at least
the songs, or at least four minutes,
which is a huge fucking chunk.
You don't want,
I just put my sweatshirt over
the clock and I'm just like,
I just peek at the clock after
every song's done. All right?
So if you just do one
a half hour of cardio,
you got to listen to rhyme of the
ancient mariner. It's a 13 minute song,
you know?
Okay.
Hi Buddy. Hey chip. Married of the whole
fucking thing. There you go. Jay showed
bye bye. [inaudible] he listened
to the whole fucking thing.
The courtesy they apart,
right?
Okay.
You're going to go from fucking
27 minutes down to 14 minutes.
He likes is a fucking joke. I
always tried to put it on, you know,
have it come on time. It was
like 21 minutes, you know,
and then I just covered up
because the next time I look,
I'm going to be in single digits. I'll
be done at like eight or nine minutes.
It's fucking tremendous.
But, um, anyways, I uh,
okay.
A buddy of mine,
my drum teacher was showing me
this fucking song this week and uh,
I dunno how I slept in this one.
I've always been a big Soundgarden fan
is somehow I never heard that song rhino
sore and a, as always, Matt came
with the sickest fucking drums.
Uh, I become obsessed with that
song in that fucking album.
And uh, when I saw it, I thought
it said 2016 I was like, oh,
they got back together.
This is their latest shit.
And then I looked again and sit in 1996
every fucking thing that I listened
to. I don't know what happened. We,
I think part of it cause I got old and
then I was also like trying to fucking
get somewhere as a comedian.
I just completely missed out on like 20
years of music and like half the shit
people show me. I'm like, that's,
that sounds fucking, you know,
it always sounds like it's brand new to
me when that come out. And they're like,
yeah, like 2002. I was like, ah, I just,
I just can't get contemporary.
I got 20 years of Shit.
I got a fucking sift through.
Um,
so if there's any other
drummers out there, you know,
part of my lessons is
they'll play shit at the end,
like ear training shit. Like you got to
try to figure out the groove you got. Oh,
you got to figure out what
time signature was in.
And this was to figure out
what time signature was in.
And of course I was fucking it
up and a few drummers out there,
it's in six,
but if you count the eighth notes,
you just count up to 12 in the
phrasing is seven and five.
Um, and I would play it for you on
here, but I always just feel like,
because I do advertising,
if I play any music,
mmm.
Then all of a sudden is going
to come after me be like,
you owe us money cause you made money
off of me on these while you played our
fucking song or whatever. Um, anyways,
what do you guys think
of the Patriot yesterday?
Everybody's flipping out about our
defense. Like, I don't know what the big,
you know, we beat the Ravens
and the Ravens did this,
they got that subs guy.
But back in the,
the edge sogs they had ray
Lewis and they had ed reed.
So they're big three is basically
down to one dude and you know,
they're not who the fuck they were.
And then we beat the Broncos in mile
high where we never fucking win.
But they basically never going to
get a rookie quarterback. I Dunno,
I get so frustrated with the Patriots
because it seems like they only protect
their offensive players. They'd been,
I know I've been bitching about this,
but they just, you know, they're fucking
cornerback. Whatever the fuck his name is,
Taylor Lib, whatever the fuck his
name is. Like he, when he was with us,
that that whole side of his whole squadron
sexual, the field was just shut down.
What didn't we like about that?
Why don't we just keep that guy,
you know, we always, we got fucking wide
receivers. We got fucking a quarterback.
That's where we keep all our fucking
man. You know what? This is my theory.
Bill Bellacheck is such a defensive
genius. I think he just thinks like,
you know what? I don't fucking
need a, you know, I don't,
I don't look at this. My fucking computer
just decided, you know, I said, hey,
do you know, contact me in an
hour. And I was like, all right.
And I was going by and I was just
thinking with my fucking phone, like,
who's doing this?
So weird.
It's like all these fucking satellites
just fucking pointed at you. I don't know.
Anyways, um, I think he just,
yeah.
Is convinced that he can take
any second round draft pick,
train this person into being a n NFL
quality player at that position slash
borderline all pearl if you,
and if you become an all pro,
Danny just fucking gets ready
at the second you want money
just fucking been doing it forever.
But back in the day, you know,
we keep McGuinness, we kept rebel. So
our defense, I felt like had an identity.
Now it's like every three years it's
like a whole new fucking defense.
It drives me up the fucking wall.
Okay.
I Dunno, we'll see. Cause
I watched the giants,
you know and you know
like all patriots fans,
every year when the
giants go on their run,
you get this sickening feeling in
your stomach going like, oh fuck yeah,
you want to play him again?
Cause we got to beat him one time.
You know when I was sitting
there going like, all right,
well they lost Tom Kaufland. This is
going to be huge. And Lo and behold,
they're doing it again. They're on
another fucking run. All right, big. Yeah,
the defense looks fucking amazing.
You know,
I'm not saying a defense
doesn't look good,
but it does not look as good
as theirs. And um, I dunno,
that's the giants thing.
Like the only thing about the giants as
they don't score any fucking points for
whatever fucking reason they got eli who's
a goddamn beast. They got the fucking,
uh, they got the diva
there. What's his name? Uh,
I don't,
my short term memory's for shit.
Yeah,
I just thought Wyatt,
I can't fucking remember his last name
is same name as the fucking soccer play
with all the tattoos.
Who's married to the spice girl.
Okay,
back up. Bend it like Beckham, Odell
Beckham. There you go. See that?
I'm learning on my fucking old brainworks
now I've got to go on one of those
brain exercise websites to try to help
you with your short term memory. Um,
I dunno, I'm fascinated how they can
have him at wide receiver. You know,
I don't know if they play in that
Cruz guy a bunch of fucking money,
but they got eli,
they're able to keep him.
But then on the other side
of the ball they got JPP.
And if he didn't fucking mess up
his hand like they, they seem to be,
they're more balanced.
Yeah.
You know, so one of Chandler Jones
wanted money. Fucking earned it.
Sometimes I just feel like we're getting,
I don't know what the fuck she built,
how many super bowls to they have to
win before you realize bill Belichick's
knows what he's doing. I know, I know.
I'm just looking at the NFC west and
it just seems like this stronger,
I'll tell you right now, the Dallas
Cowboy, you buy it, sell it. I'm selling.
I don't believe in him.
I don't believe in the Dallas cowboys.
I don't believe in that coach.
I don't know about, you know,
this is just totally based on, I
look at that guy and I go, I don't,
I don't believe in that guy.
I just don't.
Uh,
Pete Carroll is a fucking based,
Eli is an animal and their coach,
who
I swear to God looks like he
wants some radio contest is uh,
is a,
is a wolf in sheep's clothing,
is a wolf and upper deck fucking eating
a pretzel and get mustard all over his
face. Clothing. Um, I
think one of those teams,
and this is really isn't
going out on a limb,
I think one of those two
teams goes to the, uh,
to the Superbowl and having watched
both teams, I think I would rather play,
um, I rather play Seattle. And that's only
because Seattle, you know, once you went,
a couple of you went to, when a soup
bowl you go to back to back, you know,
they lost too many guys.
Um,
not to say that they could beat the
patriots every fucking beat us this year.
But, uh, we'll see bossy. I never fucking
believe in my team. You know what I mean?
I don't know why. I always just see the
fucking, you know, why are we doing this?
Why are we doing that? Um, so
anyways, we shall see. But uh,
be nice to play the giants again and
finally fucking win. We'd actually,
we would have to win that game or else
Tom Brady would forever just get ripped
on sports, talk radio, buy all his mouth
breathing dopes. They will be like, yeah,
don't,
don't do it.
Like it was just one on one game.
Like Tom Brady.
Every Superbowl has not let his team
down the field for the winning score.
He's had to do that. Every Superbowl
that he's been in, you know,
and four out of six times the defense
went out and did their job and two times
they did not.
Um,
and I'm not taking it away from fucking
Eli because two times Eli beat our
defense, but he beat our defense.
He did not be Tom Brady. However,
when you're the quarterback, you
take all the brain blame, you know,
all you gotta do is look at Dan Marino
and the ridiculous level of Shit that
that guy takes to spite the fact,
all the records that, that guy,
I've never understood it. It's just,
uh, did he have to tackle people too?
Was he supposed to run the ball up the
gut to fucking eat up some of the clock?
MMM.
I Dunno. Right? It's just so fucking the
shit that Dan Marino gets us the dumbest.
It's the dumbest ever. This is how much
the game has changed, by the way. Uh,
I looked this up the other day just
because all they do is fucking throw the
ball and I looked up all time,
you know,
running backs,
just rushing all the time for your career.
And I'll tell you right now,
what's his face? Emmitt Smith.
No one's going to break that
fucking record the way, the way,
they just don't run the
fucking ball anymore.
No one's going to get anywhere near that
thing. Uh, let me look this shit up.
Like I looked it up yesterday
and um,
not now. I don't know. Install these
fucking things. Fuck off Jesus.
It's like a
fucking kid tugging at you,
Manny. Manny, Manny, um,
where we go all time NFL rushers.
Um, all right. Where the fuck
is it? Pro Football reference.
This is the best thing ever.
So I look this shit up. Okay.
And in the top 20, top 20, all like,
as of right now, there's only
three active players in the top 20.
The first seven are all retired.
Okay. The, the, the, the highest ranking
one is Frank Gore who has 12,000,
931 yards. All right. Then you
got to go all the way down to 16.
You got Adrian Peterson who granted took
a year off because he beat his kids up
with, with something he found in
the woods. Uh, Adrian Peterson,
and then he got Steven Jackson at 18.
All right, you go to the all time.
Uh,
where the fuck is it passing?
When the hell is it passing yards?
How hard is it to find that passing yards?
All right,
so there's only,
there's only,
there's only a three active
players. Top 20 rushing, right?
Starts at eight and ends at 18.
All right.
Passing all time.
There is in the top 14,
there's six active players,
six active players in the top 14 all time.
There's only eight of the qbs in the
history of the NFL that is thrown as many
or more yards than six
current fucking players.
And the top two all time.
Our Peyton manning and Brett Farve,
Peyton manning just retired last year.
Brett Farve retired six years ago.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Like how much this game has changed.
And there's only two really
old school names, uh,
in the top 20.
Is Johnny Unitas.
Where's the other one? And
Fran Tarkington and uh, once,
what's his face like a
John Elway Warren Moon. That class? Uh,
Dan Fouts, Joe Montana. They
came in, they did their damage.
Yeah.
Do Kerry Collins is in the fucking,
he's 16th all time. So he goes,
so you got Peyton Manning's one.
Brett Farve is to drew.
Brees is three was 65,462 yards.
He's an,
he's less than 7,000
yards less. Uh, what? Six,
6,500 yards away from owning the record.
Dan Marino's fourth. Then
it's Tom Brady. John Elway,
Warren Moon than Eli Manning is eight.
Then Fran Tarkenton,
then Ben Roethlisberger, Vinny
Testaverde, Philip Rivers,
drew Bledsoe, Carson Palmer, Dan
Fouts. I've seen like everybody,
all of these people play in my lifetime.
I catch the end of friend targeting
Dan Fouts, Kerry Collins, Joe Montana,
Johnny United Stated and see
Dave Craig, boomer, Esiason,
Donovan McNabb. All right. Done.
We've Navis is 21st all time.
Um,
that's how much the fucking game has
changed. It's, it's unbelievable.
What it is, is that these guys are like
throwing for four yards, five, six yards.
It's shit he used to give to the
running back. So I think Emmitt Smith,
Walter Payton, those guys, no one's
going to touch their phone. I don't know.
I don't know how you'd get enough
fucking attempts to even do it.
Um, was there a point to that bill? I'm,
yeah, let's say they throw the ball a lot.
I guess that's what I'm saying.
Jimmer say completely changed.
And then not nothing too is just the
way that they protect the fucking
quarterback. You know, when
they call it the Tom Brady rule,
because that time he turned around
and looked at the referee, said, Hey,
somebody touched my jersey. And then
referee was like, oh, I'm sorry.
He fucking threw the flag.
Yeah.
Everybody calls it the Tom Brady rule,
which I love.
I love that they call it the Tom
Brady rule. Cause it is, you know,
you gotta protect your quarterback, sets
your money. Everybody realizes that, uh,
you know, when, when the best, you know,
everybody knows the fucking quarterback.
That guy gets knocked out.
No one's going to watch the game.
So they protect the hell out of them and
they're like, yeah, fuck everybody else.
And uh, people who not into
sports, they're into offense.
They want to see some action.
So they just, they, you know,
now it's like a legal to cover,
cover a fucking receiver
to Dan Marino did the shit you could
do during that guy's fucking career and
he's still through for like
60,000 fucking yards. I Dunno
if he's talking about steroids.
Right.
And then they put an asterisk next
to your name. You know, they don't,
you don't have those same way they
don't give Barry bonds is just do,
it's just like, Hey, are you going
to sit there and tell me, you know,
all of these fucking guys were as
good as Dan Marino with the yard.
So putting up the fuck out
of here. All right. Um,
in Feis age difference
and history a dear bill,
I'm just a bill. Yes. I'm only a
bill. Um, I'm a big fan of yours.
I really enjoy your podcast, your,
thank you very much. I appreciate it.
I am 28 years old and in a relationship
with my girlfriend who's seven years
younger than me and who I plan on
marrying were really great together.
I love her. Well congratulations.
The thing is is as our
relationship has gone on,
we've slashed, I've been getting some
static from people about our relationship.
Well who gives a fuck what they think?
Like I said,
she's seven years younger than me,
but we've known each other for a while.
We've met when I was working at my first
job as a counselor at a camp when she
was one of the kids.
Oh Jesus.
When we first met I was 17 and she was 10.
Yeah.
Uh Yeah Yap, Yap man. There that,
that's that creepy thing.
That's that creepy hippie
thing. Cause at some point you were
like, oh look at that little kid.
That's the woody Allen moment where
you go, oh, isn't she adorable?
And then at some point the
switch flips to be in like, Hey,
I think I want to fuck
that. You know, there's,
there's no way to get around that sir.
He'd have to understand that. So anyways,
he says nothing happened between us
at that point. Well, I would hope so.
It wasn't until we reconnected years
later when we were older that we started
talking again and really getting
to know each other. All right,
well I guess that's fair, but people are
going to say some shit. Right? Anyway,
I'm getting shit from some family
and friends because of our history.
Just from an outside source.
I'd like to know what you think.
Do you think it's strange or weird?
I know there's people out there 15 to 20
years apart. It's just with our history,
it throws people off again.
What do you think from an
unbiased perspective perspective?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
The thing is is that you were 17 and
she was 10 when you first met her. Um,
that's what makes it weird.
MMM.
Like my wife is 10 years younger than me,
but I didn't meet her until I was like,
you know,
35 and she was 25.
MMM.
Hey Nia, come in. Here is a question.
Somebody, uh, somebody is a 28,
what did he say? That Wendy
Hoodie. So out of breath for
come here. Yeah. You need a place
to sit here. Yeah. Jesus. Yeah.
So this guy, he's dating this
woman, right? He wants to marry.
He's 28 she's 21 he said, the thing
is, I met her when I was a counselor.
I was 17 she was only 10 he goes,
obviously right,
nothing happened.
Then
he goes, obviously nothing happened
then, but now that we're together,
people are given a shit.
And I was saying how there was a 10 year
difference between us, but I, you know,
I was 35 yeah,
25 right. So, so they're
looking at you like, uh,
you've been grooming her since she
was like seven years old. Yeah.
But he like met her but then didn't
seem like he didn't see her for a while.
Then they reconnected and had
all the chorus, which happens.
Don't worry about it if you know
everything's on the up and up.
Just just do your thing. Yeah.
Is there a family cool with it,
you know,
is her family given him the side eye?
Like he was grooming her or
seems to just be friends.
What do you mean? His friends?
People that he knows it just like,
this is what I would do.
I would just,
whatever those Pete runs are giving
him shit about it. I wouldn't,
if you meet new people, I wouldn't tell
them that that's how you first met him.
Probably not.
And not everybody needs to know your
entire history and that way just because
people will misinterpret it. But
yeah. Have you guys are fine.
Your family's are fine. Like
don't worry about it. Yeah.
As long as nothing happen when
you were a counselor. Exactly.
As long as you're sure nothing
happened when you were a council there,
which I'm sure they didn't, he always
wants to push her on this. Swink oh God.
I know.
It's bad.
All right. I want to see, I did it to you.
Sorry. You're gonna you're gonna have to,
you know, this is certain level of shit
you're going to have to deal with. Um,
where are you going?
I'm going. I'm going out to have a
little, a little breakfast with a friend.
I didn't like the vagueness of that.
Having a little with a friend.
I'm going to get smoothies with Chelsea
Peretti. Oh, he didn't have to say that.
Smoothies.
Chelsea Peretti
Sacramento zone. Chelsea Peretti. Yeah,
she's from Sacramento.
No, Hella Sacramento.
Um, she's white trash
from, uh, yes she is.
She's white trash from
northern California and she is,
she's also a Republican. Um, anyway.
All right. Where the fuck am I? Um, yeah,
I do it just, you know who gives a fuck?
This is the deal. Once you get married,
you have fucking kids and shit.
You're never going to see anybody anyway.
So who gives a fuck?
Who gives a fuck what people think?
Go out and do what makes you happy.
Okay. As long as you're not hurting
anybody and you're not breaking a law,
please go out and do it before.
Just being happy becomes
illegal because, uh, you know,
just the level that the
population is going in, you know,
I'm thinking by the end of my life,
I don't know what it's
going to be like over here.
I hope we don't end up like China. With
China. It's so fucking overpopulated.
They've got to like people, nobody
drive cars for like five fucking days.
And just the shit that they're dealing
with is a, it's brutal over there.
What are you doing? Yeah, take
the priests, take the priests.
I still have the Prius. Everybody.
I'm going to be selling the car.
I just can't find the title.
So I sent,
I sent in all the forms to the DMV.
Bye.
Enjoy your smoothies.
You big Hollywood phony.
Alright. Um, so I sent it in
to the local one and I fucked up.
Not only did I send it to the wrong DMV,
I wrote for some reason 2017 on the check.
So they thought I was trying to
be pull a fast one. So then, uh,
I ended up having to send
it up to fucking Sacramento,
some waiting for that thing so I
can finally get rid of that other,
the fucking car. Um, all right,
here we go. Girlfriend texts.
Hey Bill, I'm in in a bit of a
tough situation. I think you are.
You wrote in twice and we'd love
to hear your take it on it. Uh,
I'm 24 years old and was recently
seeing a 33 year old girl.
Whoa.
I love it.
Okay.
Bought out. Who Do, do,
do calm and rubbed my fucking balls.
You are fucking nine years older.
Um,
for about six months. Uh, within the
time span I cheated on her twice.
I told her about it and
although she was upset,
we agreed to get back together
and start over a new, uh,
everything was relatively
fine until last week.
I went to her house before she got off
of work to do some work on our computer.
When I noticed her text messages opened.
Oh,
mac computers are usually
linked to a person's phone.
So I was able to see all of her texts.
I'm sure you know by now where
this is going. Oh, Jay. Jay's,
um, since she has gone
through my texts before,
I figured I would take the
same evasive liberty. Well,
you've fucked around on a twice. I would
think that she would be doing that. Uh,
I found a particularly strange thread
from someone named Lauren who am I found
out was actually her ex boyfriend and she
had it in her phone in a woman's name.
Oh God. They were sexting back and forth,
talking dirty and exchanging pictures.
I also found out she was sending
him videos of us having sex.
What the fuck?
Whoa,
dude. That's, I don't think that's legal.
Okay.
Is that legal weight? Did you
consider, oh wait, how does that work?
If you could essentially let somebody,
if you didn't know you were being filmed.
I don't think that that's legal.
This is what I do know. I'm not a
lawyer and I have no idea what the lies.
All right,
let's continue.
I confronted her on it and at first she
minimize the entire situation saying it
wasn't really that big of a deal.
Since then, we've been going back
and forth arguing, you know what,
you guys are both like not ready to be
in relationships remotely and thank God
you both found this out before
you got married and had kids.
She sends apologize,
but I'm not really sure what to do.
I did cheat on her.
So does that even the playing field
or is the whole thing just rooted in
disfunction and chaos? There
you go. Walk towards the light.
I can't tell if I'm just lonely
and want her in my life again,
or if I should just walk away.
Please help me here.
I am emotionally involved
in this situation,
so it's hard to make a clear objective
call to just walk away, walk away,
and you need to do some work
on yourself because, uh,
I think you're a fucked up dude. Um,
and I'm, I'm saying this with empathy.
Uh, you're a fucked up dude was actually
relationship guy and probably would have
just gotten married and fucking had
your own little fucking fruit stand or
whatever. But something fucked
up happening. He was a kid.
You got weird boundaries.
So you get into relationships with
dysfunctional fucking people and then you
could consider continue to fuck around
on the side and all that. The, it's, um,
it's actually a very common
thing. So I would say, uh,
what you need is you need
to be single and, uh,
you need to do some work on yourself.
I'd may would go to therapy,
figure out what your deal is,
really figure out what the fuck it is
that you want in life and what it is that
you're looking for. And then just take
a baby step everyday walking towards it.
That's what I would do, but I would
get out of this relationship. Um,
and I would give her the same advice
to, um, [inaudible]. There you go. Yeah.
Get out of it. And uh, and just know
that you're going to be fucking lonely.
But it, all it takes is like, do you
know, two to three months you'll be fine.
You know what I mean? Just make yourself
go to the gym. What you gotta do is you,
you're breaking a routine and you fucking
use to this person being in your life.
But like the further you go
without seeing that person,
the more objective you can be.
And you can look back and then one
day you're just going to be like,
what the fuck was I thinking?
MMM.
And it can actually be funny to you or
you can really just see like, like uh,
like what the fuck is wrong with me?
That I would do that to a person and what
is wrong with me that someone would do
that to me and I would consider
staying. Uh, you need some self esteem.
Their buddy. Um, all
right, girl with pet rat.
Okay.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Dear Billy Christmas toes.
I don't know what that means. I've been
listening to the podcast for a long time.
I recently came into a situation that
resulted in me having to make a decision
instead of writing into you and
asking what to do in this situation.
I decided to do what I thought you would
want me to do and write in what the
results.
Dude,
don't base your life on what the
fuck you think I would want to do.
But this is already interesting.
Last month a girl I'd
been dating got a pet rat
boy got a pet fucking rat.
Okay.
Is it Angelina Jolie,
then she have a rat or no shits.
Billy Bob's blood around her neck.
We had been dating for about four
months and it was going well.
I would say that if we were
together about six months,
I would have moved in with her.
We really clicked well.
She got a pet rat and I
wasn't down with that.
Not because I had a problem
with a rat in a cage,
but her taking the rat out of the cage
and holding it while we watched a movie.
Okay.
Bill, I can barely even stand a cat
on a lap because I don't trust them.
So I voiced my concern and she laughed
them off and ended up being a bigger
argument and eventually
came back around to the rat.
I told her it was me or the rat.
She said she'd rather me, Oh, you missed
a word here. She'd rather have me,
I guess, except there was a long
pause and some serious thought.
I really liked this girl.
And honestly,
if my devotion ever came down to
choosing between her in anything short of
family or friends, uh, would she,
are any girl ever except that.
Okay.
Dude, you're so emotional. You
skipping words here. Probably not,
they'd say bail on the guy who's not
sure if he choose you or something that
potentially spreads diseases.
Anyways, that's what happened.
Merry Christmas to the burrs.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
but what's you're doing is she loves
that rat and you're making her get rid of
something that she loves.
So there's going to be,
I guess a pause.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I think that it was really bugging you.
I think it was really fucking bothering
you and you let it simmer and then you
just fucking hit her with,
you know,
you were ready to talk
about this for days, weeks,
I don't know how long.
And then you just fucking caught her off
guard and she's been bonding with this
thing and you made her make a Sophie's
choice between you or the rat,
which, um, I gotta tell you,
I don't know about that move.
I Dunno about that move.
You could have easily just said,
listen,
I respect the fact that you like a rat.
Okay.
For,
you know what the first thing I would do
is I would look up life expectancy of a
rat. All right? And I don't
mean someone that snitches,
cause I think everybody even I
know at this age is white as I am,
that snitches get stitches.
Snapchat. Um, all right.
Life expectancy. What do you guys
think of? What's the over under here?
How long can a fucking Ratliff,
I'm gonna say they live
six to eight years,
you know, if those are the prices, right.
And I was the last person to fucking,
I would say six. I'm gonna say eight,
eight years. Life expectancy of a rat.
Uh, two years do it only lives
for fucking two years. All right?
This is what you say to her.
If she hasn't gotten rid of the rat,
come back and say, listen, I know
he loved that. Fucking wrote it.
Um, here's the deal. The
things only lived two years.
All right. I plan on being with you
in two years. Can you do me a favor?
Make this be the only rat he
ever have. All right. Okay.
She agrees to that thing and
then just put parameters.
When I come over and we're
watching sleepless in Seattle,
I don't want to have a threesome,
if you know what I mean.
Just keep it in the fucking
cage when I'm not here.
You want to roll around the floor,
get yellow fever,
whatever the fuck you want to do.
Whatever the fuck rats do.
If you want to do that,
that's fine. I just, you know,
I don't want to fucking deal
with the thing. You could've
done that, but you know,
you kind of made her a like what
she going to do with the rat now?
Like how do you get rid of a rat?
Is there like a fucking adoption agency?
They didn't make me feel bad about my dog
again, which is of course been brutal.
Or am I going to talk
about it? All right. Um,
yeah,
yeah. You just let the fucking
thing go. Do you know those lines?
Do you know when the twins,
those people have those fucking
lions and tigers and cheetahs,
fern long enough time.
They can't release them back into the
wild because they don't even know how to
fucking hunt anymore. You know what
I mean? That really blew my mind.
They don't have to hunt anymore,
but they can murder a fucking housekeeper.
I mean, he's just had a fuck.
Do you have that in the house?
There's no fucking,
this
was in Kuwait, by the way. I don't
know why I said Saudi Arabia. Kuwait.
Exotic
pet deaths.
Let's see what we got here.
Lions. Tigers to come. Problems.
Pets in golf.
MMM.
Big Cat killings. Smallings
big cats escape, right?
Here we go. This is 2014 this
is a website you want to go to?
Big Cat. Big Cat rescue.
All right. Big Cat killings.
Molly's and escapes.
2000 tens before a lion.
Attacks on humans.
Here's a video I don't do.
I want to watch this and is it weird
that I root for the fucking animals?
Oh, Jesus Christ down right
to look at those things. We,
I was talking to [inaudible] and we were
talking about these big cats like those
big cats. They literally the
Lamborghini's and Ferrari's of fucking,
of cats. Of Animals. Oh my God.
Okay.
It's fucking,
it's got his fucking arm.
It's got his fucking arm and
he's trying to slap at it.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Jesus fucking,
you're a fucking idiot.
This guy is trying to remain calm.
Okay.
This is dude.
There's one guy,
he's dealing with this lion
attacking him and then the fucking,
there's another guy slapping at the
fucking lion and it's got his fucking leg.
It's just sort of holding him.
He's almost a way.
Oh my God.
He's fucking got him again.
Okay,
dude, you should have got the fuck out
of there. Get the fuck out of there.
And this guy,
he's still staying in the fucking cage.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, go. You fucking dope. Oh,
this is like the top 10 all right.
You got to go to this big cat rescue.org.
Yeah,
and this is another guy. He's getting
fucking bit by this goddamn thing.
It's weird,
man.
When they decide that they're going after
somebody liked the other guy can just
totally be like,
get the F,
you know the other guys like the
friend and the bark on, come on man,
you don't need this.
You don't need this.
This thing is just going
after this one fucking dude.
Lion attack number rate. All right.
He's petting the back of the thing.
He's patent it, you know, it's a fucking
line. And then boom, oh, it's got his arm.
I've seen this one.
It's got his fucking arm.
Uh,
now his friends,
his friends are pulling,
it's a tug of war with this guy right now.
And the other guy is funny.
He tries to hit the line,
but he's too afraid to go near it.
So he keeps hitting his friend
who has it in his fucking mouth.
Wow. Lion attacks hunter.
I've seen this one.
I don't like that one because they
killed the fucking light. Jesus Christ.
You know what I gotta be honest with you,
what you don't see in any of these
fucking videos is women that own fucking
these things. You know, guys is just such
fucking dope. Um, anyways. All right,
that's the podcast for this week. And if
you guys miss last Thursday's podcasts,
um, you got to tune into
a bridge. Shied. No, man,
this guy gives you basically eight
standup comedy history class.
He's one of my favorite guest
I've ever had on the podcast.
I could've talked to him for like two
hours. You have to get his book. Um,
you know,
it's about his life as a standup comedian
was at walking through the ashes of
standup my life as a standup comedian.
You got to get the book because, you know,
he started to tell me those Johnny
first time he did the tonight show,
he had cocaine bag, a little Baggie
of cocaine in his fucking pocket.
He said the next time he did it,
he did a joke about heart attacks and
Johnny was really nervous about having a
heart attack because he smoked in,
hated him,
and they made sure that he stayed in the
fucking dressing room and they're like,
you never do in the show again, and Blah,
Blah Blah and all this type of shit.
It's fucking, the book is amazing. Um, but
you got to listen. Listen to the podcast.
We, I have the links and everything.
That was last Thursday's pull.
If you're really a fan of stand
up, um, it was just effortless.
It was one of the fastest hours
have ever done in the podcast.
Totally fascinating. Please check it out.
It was from, uh, what's Today's date?
I don't fucking know. It was last
Thursday. Goddammit, Bill. Let's see.
Thursday, the, uh, let's see. 11, 12, 13,
14 of the 15th. That Jesus,
Bill, come on. Can you,
can you get your shit together here? All
right. 2016. Yeah. Thursday the 15th.
Check that one. All right, that's
podcasts. Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll check in on Thursday.